Speaker 1: Let's go next to Ryan from
New York. Ryan, you're on the air.
Speaker 6: Can you hear me? Yes, I can. OK,
awesome. Thanks. Plus, I just had a quick
question regarding something that was said to me.
It's becoming American national, and I think it
has something to do with the sovereign movement.
And I'm not sure if you had already put up any
content on this stuff, but I wanted to see if you
had heard about it and what your take was on that.
Speaker 1: Wait a second. So it's a
movement called American National.
Speaker 6: Yes, I think it's called like
becoming an American national. Are you
denounce your citizenship from the United States?
Speaker 1: Oh, and it's part of the sovereign
citizen movement. Yeah, I've heard about.
I'm not familiar with this one in particular.
I've heard about these before. If people
want to see something really entertaining,
check out my interview a long time ago with a
guy named David Wynn Miller, who believed that
by adding elements of punctuation to your
name like extraneous semicolons and dashes,
you became a nontaxable, sort of like sovereign
person and didn't owe any taxes to the government.
None of this stuff ever holds up legally, so
I know that there's people who want to do it,
but courts will still drag you in and they'll
still send you to jail. I mean, it's it's a
really wacky movement, and unfortunately, it's not
only benign because sometimes they get violent.
Speaker 6: Yes, OK. Yeah. Thank you for answer.
I'll definitely check out that interview.
Speaker 1: You're not you're not thinking of
becoming a sovereign citizen, are you, Ryan?
Speaker 5: I am not. OK, all right.
Speaker 1: I don't think it's good for anyone's
career, family life or overall well-being.
Speaker 6: No. Yeah, I was like, I just talked
to some people, and that seems to be where their
heads that they favor the United States. We were
unlawfully converted into citizens. Right? Or all
these different things. So I would just kind of
wondering because I don't really subscribe to
that mindset, but I sometimes don't really know
what to say to them. So I'm just like, OK, yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, I guess often it's it's a lot
of the points are similar to when libertarians
just say taxes are slavery and you never agreed to
them. It's sort of like, OK, well, so how did you
end up in this country? And somebody might say,
Well, I was born here, and then you would
say, OK, so so your parents decided to birth
you in this country, right? And they'd say,
Yeah, it's like, OK, well, do you believe in
parental custody until kids are 18? And it's
like, if you do, then your parents decided for
you. They opted un by choosing to birth you in
the United States. And then they might say, well,
but my parents didn't choose to be citizens of
the United States, and then you just go up and
eventually it's someone who moved to the U.S.
So then it's like, OK, so they knowingly came
to the United States knowing that they would be
subject to the laws here, right? So they chose
and then the next generation chose to have a
kid. You know, it's so boring, but it's like,
that's the kind of way you've got to deal with it.
Speaker 6: OK. Yeah. Yes. Thank you.
Speaker 1: Appreciate it. All right.
No problem. There's Ryan Ryan. Yeah,
those movements will rot your brain.
It's good to be very, very careful.